es ist doch absurd dass werner
industrienationen leben und die
kanzlerin sagen muss bei 75 prozent der
fälle haben wir keine ahnung wo sich die
menschen anstecken
das stimmt gar nicht unsere handys
wissen ist die korona es bei 20
millionen handys installiert und dort
sind gps da da in wir endlich zu lassen
würden auf diese daten zugreifen hätten
wir in kürzester zeit hunderttausende
von datensätzen das den der endlich
erkennen können wo das virus sich
eigentlich ausbreitet an welchen orten
und daraus kann man wissenschaftlich
ableiten welche situationen sind die wir
beherrschen müssen
wir müssen runter von diesem datenschutz
kohl das muss bis 10 januar gelingen das
zugriff auf diese informationen der app
ermöglicht wird und dass sie so
ausgerollt wird dass sie auch wirklich
verpflichtend für alle den
entsprechendes handy haben denn zur
nutzung vorgeschrieben wird wir können
doch nicht den leuten weihnachten das
einkaufen dass freunde besuchen alles
mögliche verbieten aber davor
zurückschrecken endlich die modernen
techniken zu nutzen wie der südkorea und
taiwan hoch erfolgreich gemacht haben
ich erwarte dass darüber jetzt endlich
mal eine offene diskussion geführt wird
die grundrechts einschränkungen sind
viel härter als das was wir beim
datenschutz erreichen können und ich bin
schon seit april in die öffentlichkeit
mit der these getreten ich verzichte auf
meine daten kontrolle wenn dafür der
staat bescheid weiß wo sich dieses virus
bewegt weil es bewegt sich ja immer in
menschen und darüber müssen wir
diskutieren und ob uns diese eingriffe
in die privatsphäre was die daten angeht
ob uns die schwerwiegende erscheinen
oder der eingriff dass ich jetzt nicht
mehr als fünf erwachsene personen an
weihnachten oder vor weihnachten treffen
kann möglicherweise die nachbarn die
polizei rufen bei der sechs erwachsene
sind die politische debatte wo wir
ansetzen ist nötig wenn ich würde gerne
für ein halbes jahr auf dem datenschutz
verzichten in die gesundheitsämter
endlich wissen wo dieses virus sich
ausbreiten